it's awesome anarchists and socialists
ruining other people's lunch just to
make them miserable before the check
comes it's pure unconscious brain
function we're screaming and other
reflexes are only possible if it doesn't
involve actual thinking this is what
fascism looks like when it first puts on
its baby jackboots it's so adorable when
they first try to walk in them
I feel for their families but I know
their families don't talk to them they
just send money because people like this
don't have jobs what we're seeing is a
contagion this is what failure looks
like unemployable Yahoo's who join a mob
and demand people with jobs just give up
it's physically repulsive I mean
literally physically repulsive meaning
it's time for a Gregg's golden rule of
anger
thou shalt not yell check out that beard
that's commandment 12 it's right there
the more you yell the better it feels
but the worse you look just watch
severe cold oh I love her but she is
just thinking what Rosie's saying I
believe he should be impeached I'm
sickened by Congress that doesn't call
for articles of impeachment we have to
fight with everything we got because if
somehow they're able to rig the
elections again as I believe they did in
2016 then we're going to all be in
trouble as democracy dies right here on
our watch looks like fun in fact Rosie
seems like a perfect fit for the
resistance if the Democrats don't make
her their 2020 candidate they're missing
the boat meanwhile West Hollywood the
democratic council bravely voted to
remove Trump's Walk of Fame star yeah
I'm sure that really ruined Trump's day
sorry of losing your star on the Walk of
Fame is the price you pay for being a
president who gets stuff done you know
where you can stick that star